when Aaron steers comes to the NOI
marked public square and sees the
restored Gowen Curia he is reminded of
the Dresden bombings 75 years ago
everything was destroyed and this was
where most of the people were killed in
the firestorm then on the next day the
dayson funkier collapsed yes this square
was reduced to rubble and more booths
than they on the evening of February
13th 1945 over the span of just 15
minutes the Allied forces dropped bombs
containing 900 tons of explosives on
Dresden during the next two days three
more attack waves followed after that
the baroque old town lay in ruins at the
time Ernst Hirsch was 9 years old when
the bombs were dropped on Dresden he and
his parents hid in a bomb shelter in the
cellar of their house seen here in the
former Johann Georg an alley after the
first attack we left the apartment while
everything was burning I can still see
it before my eyes the flames creeping
over the rooftops of neighboring houses
and that's what it looked like
afterwards that was my parents
apartments on the top that's what the
ruins look like and you can see the
facade was still in good shape but
inside the building everything was
burned out and that's what the whole
wonderful Street looked like Ernst here
sent his parents were lucky they were
able to flee the city as many as 25,000
people died during the air raids many of
them suffocated during the firestorms
unpleasantness in my eyes this was a war
crime many things happened on all sides
but this was an act of destruction
directed at the civilian population
ansed here started working as a
cameraman in the 1950s his nickname was
the I of Dresden he documented the
reconstruction of the destroyed city and
he's been collecting photos and videos
of Dresden since the nineteenth century
for his film archives documentary film
can be brutally honest if you do not
edit or change the footage and I never
did this then for me it is the most
impressive historical witness likeness
today the rebuilt cityscape of Dresden
betrays few signs of the destruction
that took place here seventy-five years
ago the most wonderful thing of all is
that the Dresden frauenkirche er has
been restored that is really the biggest
miracle and after the destruction I
experienced in my childhood and youth I
never hoped or expected this to happen I
hope it will stay this way forever The
Dresden frauenkirche er is where Ernst
Hirsch was baptised before the war today
he sees it as a symbol of peace
so was Dresden a legitimate target or a
war crime to talk about that I have with
us our correspondent Kate Brady she's in
Dresden as well as between the studio DW
analyst and John barek welcome to both
of you if I may start with you John now
we heard the survivor in our report an
snitch he described what happened in
Dresden today 75 years ago as a war
crime what is your assessment it's a
difficult question to answer it simply
and because there is controversy about
it among historians and legal experts
the short answer though I think is the
consensus is by the standards of the
time it it was not a war crime there was
carpet bombing so-called strategic
bombing of cities in order to demoralize
the populations done by both sides and
it was considered at the time legitimate
of course if it were to happen today it
would definitely certainly be regarded
as a war crime turning to you now a kid
I mean the far right in Germany
is using these commemorations in Dresden
in a very targeted and particular way
tell us more about their perception and
strategy well Emery to the far right
scene and neo-nazis here in Germany have
been instrumentalizing these
commemorations of The Dresden bombing
for many many years now as part of their
their propaganda and that all stems
really from immediately after the raid
75 years ago when the Nazis who were of
course still in power at the time really
adjusted those numbers quoting number of
deaths and casualties manipulated those
figures saying that anywhere between
200,000 and half a million people
perished in this tragic bombing but of
course nowadays we know that they was
actually around 25 people 25,000 people
who perished in these in these air raids
and the firestorm that took hold of
Dresden just behind me on the other side
of the Elbe and of course this year we
are expecting to see the far-right March
again this weekend today we are
expecting to be to not really see
anything of the far-right scene but on
Saturday
here in Dresden they're expected to hold
a demonstration or at our marsh as they
call it a sense of a march of mourning
to remember the victims and so we're
still seeing this increment
instrumentalization continuing today and
we're expected to see people from not
only Germany's far right scene but
people are expected to descend on
Dresden from across Europe as well in
John the narrative surrounding the
destruction of Dresden has been
instrumentalized not just now as Kate
was telling us but right from the start
tell us more about that well years of
gurbles who was the Nazi propaganda
minister on the day after the first wave
of bombing not only exaggerated the
numbers as Kate mentioned quite rightly
he also suggested that it was women
refugees and children who had been
killed and that Dresden was not
militarily significant it was a that the
aim of the targeting was it was against
the cultural city of Dresden now that
simply a lie of course also there was
hatred azure wizened revenge thoughts of
revenge and the allies and they were
targeting civilians as well quite
clearly but Dresden had a very
significant military position at the
time the Red Army was advancing from
Russia had already crossed into German
territory was surging towards Berlin the
capital Germany had not yet surrendered
and Dresden was a garrison city with
20,000 troops there with armament
factories and was also the main rail hub
to the east the supplying armaments to
the to the to the to the to the German
forces fighting the Russians so there
were also military reasons for attacking
it the problem is that this has been
instrumentalized particularly by the
right wing in Germany and by Holocaust
deniers such as David Irving the world
over who try to bring this often in
connection with the Holocaust they try
to relativize the genocide against the
Jews by exaggerating the death tolls and
the suffering as terrible as they were
in Dresden get your stand
in the heart of Dresden what do people
there feel about this debate and these
conflicting narratives that we are
getting
well Dresdeners today I'm Rita not only
want to remember the victims of the air
raid 75 years ago but they also want to
use the memorial and the commemorations
today to take a look at exactly what's
happening in the present and how we
today how society today can learn from
the atrocities of the past and I think
that's reflected in the commemorations
taking place today
if you look at the front of the program
for the service later today today it
simply says nisht Ferguson meaning just
to not forget and I think that will be
shown as well later this evening when
tens around 10,000 people are due to
unite around Dresden across both sides
of the river Elbe behind me to unite and
create a human chain and that is
supposed to create a signal of unity
against all signs of hate I hate Road
and violence and of course German
president frankfurter Steinmeier will
also be taking part so the the
commemorations today are not only about
remembering the past but also reflecting
on what can be learned and applied to
the present day
get ready in Dresden and John Burak DW
is analyst here thank you both very much
for your perspectives